merci à tous d'être venus si maggie
était là elle elle vous dirai à tous de
faire comme chez vous ce qui avait de
mieux chez maguy c'est qu'elle aimait
profondément jenny pour être honnête
j'aurais pu être un meilleur père
maintenant je dois faire ça je dois être
un super papa pour jenny
comment tu t'en sors mon pote j'arrive
pas à croire qu'elle soit morte
chez moi les choses sont devenues un peu
bizarre qu'est ce que tu fais bébé fait
la peinture m'a pas ton avis mais maman
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
comment elle va jenny a dit qu'elle
avait vu quelque chose dans sa chambre
est ce que tu as vu ça
c'est une âme en colère qui est piégé
dans ce monde
j'ai senti une présence
c'est le mal
jenny viens jouer avec moi samantha
ce sont les ténèbres
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire du mal
les celtes haineuses envoyées un message
on doit pas faire de bruit au risque
at-elle effrayer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]